he's a kid from San Diego who's made
good to say the least rapper actor
comedian director screenwriter film
producer entrepreneur record producer I
don't know if I've missed anything all
your radio and TV personality and the
best color commentator I've ever done a
celebrity beach volleyball game with
audience he is the man who is written
directive an executive reduced executive
produced king of the dancehall that's on
YouTube red that's Wednesday and also
season nine of wild and out on MTV good
to see you Nick Kennedy see you too my
friend
so how has that beach volleyball game
that we call me Harry waltz Jenni sunk
in its AME next week's later it was like
a whole new career experience for me I
got a bunch of jobs I was I probably
could do this one too I had a good time
out there lots of sand no but it was a
good atmosphere yeah and you really got
into it when the Backstreet Boys came up
with that big time to come back back
back streets back apparently have they
been talking about it on any of the
streets man you know it was it was so
interesting to see that energy down
there I mean it was a lot of fun but
like people were going it was like like
thirty five-year-old groupies out there
right where the Backstreet Boys going
crazy so when you grew up in San Diego
did you ever try sports you ever get a
work give it a world oh I mean I'm I've
done martial arts all my life you know
so I mean I say you don't play martial
arts but it's definitely something
that's a competitive act that you know I
grew up with skills trained to this day
okay so I do a few different things but
other than that so because I was so
focused on martial arts and obviously
entertainment I didn't I didn't really
excel at any other sport because most of
my day was taken up either you know it
training in the gym you know kickboxing
yes you ever tried you ever think about
trying to MMA or anything like no what I
was so it there's such this real
spiritual doctrine about martial arts
for me that when the world of it and
they came around for me I kind of wasn't
I wasn't really there for because I was
so deep into like kung-fu and Taekwondo
I mean I'm a boxed a little bit so I'm
just now starting to get into it a
little bit more because you know it's so
popular now but before I was always kind
of looking
oh well I do it for spiritual growth not
competition so you're doing that we
aspect of course just your your inner
right with cheese make sense okay
there's your working your inner cheese
well I thought you were going to say you
saw the Karate Kid again I just win it
then you start painting the fernback
your waxing [ __ ] you know what growing
up doing martial arts I would it was
actually not a good thing for me because
of stuff like The Karate Kid because it
was the kid walking through the projects
with a karate uniform on that's that's a
target is that what you were doing yeah
they were just you know I would get
picked on and beat up all the time
because you know it was you got a few
points for saying you beat up the Karate
Kid but then again you would have some
sort of way to strike back of course but
it's still like if always saying the
other person isn't doing karate with you
yeah it's you do female good for like
eight-year-old sure somebody's gonna
pouch you in the head with a rock like
Nick Cannon here on the Rich Eisen show
studio so when did you realize that
comedy was a way that you could I didn't
always love kids that just yearned for
attention and it started more with music
and in the church and you know just
really wanting attention watching my
father you know speak in front of
congregation is that was really
intriguing to me I knew I would never be
a preacher because I was too much of a
sinner so maybe I could like you know
entertain people with my humor with
music and that's kind of opened up like
early on so who was he
towards the inspiration for you on the
comedic front uh yeah who did your back
my 80s baby so call things Eddie Murphy
Murphy you like Eddie Murphy barking rod
the Mary a delirious when he's on
Saturday Night Live like I and I would
be around the house I was obviously
never allowed to watch a viewer listen
to any of those things what to say David
your father with creature screeching the
Kenny Murphy delirious and raw would not
be all bad so I was like but I would do
all these impersonations and I would
like kind of watered-down
the material for like church audiences
and you know it kind of worked it was
cute and you know it back then and then
eventually I develop my own material
so then what
what athletes have come up to you Nick
and said that they enjoy your your
material ah me what which athletes have
you come across I mean I've had quite a
few of my friends on a while and out
like who obviously Shaq's been on the
show you know Chris Paul has been on the
show we still waiting to get a lot of
the NFL and MLB guys on there but we I
mean I mean we had Michael Strahan on
the show a lot of a lot of fun people
they usually wait until they're like
retired to come on because we start
making fun of them and you know on
wiling out then they got to hear about
that for quite some time so it's you be
the guy that like I know how to take a
joke massa
so let's get into the this maybe the
third rail here Nick but we're going to
go right for a zero fourth is Shaq a
good rapper ooh see we did this is a
debate in the hip-hop community please
uh it's a real debate it is a real
debate because you this is why this is a
real debate and Shaq you like a family
member to me okay that's why I mentioned
third round yeah only reason Shaq
I'm a fan exec has platinum albums I
don't I have no but I mean to speak on
Shaq music career well I mean and you
have you know five million Twitter
followers a sec I don't even know you
might be multiples of that I thought
that's ethnic I mean you're so I would
say like numbers don't lie and he has
done some phenomenal things in like Shaq
has recordings with with Biggie Smalls
and been on stage with jay-z like Shaq
is he had the credential but do they
want to be on the stage because it is
rapping ability or they just love shot
at basketball player and want to be
around him but he's sold millions of
Records
okay everyone likes it jack is probably
the not just the biggest but one of the
best entertainers we've seen this
century I had to give it to all the way
around
Kazaam
come on man well I mean Kazaam was was a
movie about it's good to feel right
doesn't mean oh he was real cheese and
blue chips too okay he was him it wasn't
petty harder wait here and let you guys
ridicule my know we love chef lacking
amazing and it's a I played the push
nickens back that taken we've got what's
up doc can we ride come on is the only
line in the Sun I'll take 60 seconds
more with Nick Cannon we'll talk about
season nine of wild and out king of the
dancehall but you an is on YouTube red
this Wednesday I mean you got Whoopi
Goldberg Busta Rhymes Shaq not in this
no you sure sure brother I couldn't do
dance although we've seen a rap me right
do some dancehall Luis Gossett jr. is in
this so he's not asking Shaq for his
deal are from rapping hey we're back in
60 seconds with Nick Cannon here on the
Rich Eisen show one of the many reasons
why I love doing this show is I did not
wake up this morning knowing that Nick
Cannon was coming into the show today
thinking I would be talking about fouché
nickens and haha
but sometimes lie had little three
curves
yeah absolutely as we read now hang in
with Nick Cannon you're on the Rich
Eisen show Omar Epps and Patrick
Peterson and our number three coming up
you are also a very fashionable
individual your thank you your rocket
what what shoes do you have on these
would be some glittery Giuseppe's it
reads literally splitter gold golden
glitter mic like it and matches the
shirt as well as with the your Hannah
hat fedora fedora you're wrong pocket
square has some gold highlights in it a
windowpane brown suit the whole thing is
two knots neck their day so I'd like to
show you a picture if we can put Cam
Newton from the other day Cameron showed
up at his press conference Oh
wearing that I think everybody in the
radio audience knows what what we're
looking at what are your thoughts on
Cameron style right there right head
very nice okay to add I mean unnamed
what are those shorts are
those swim trunks yeah they fresh out
the locker room or is this wisdom
Brockman do we know the circumstances
here we don't he does he mean he
obviously had practice
is that a crop top when you're a man of
that stature just you can get away with
anything yes I agree if I wore that I'd
look like Arkell but that man he still
looks manly in that that leaves you know
that I and I'd salute anyone who can
make a statement
I agree he's also been wearing jumpers
and stuff around very all right there
that robber at Coachella Coachella pink
shoes and I'm a very fashion-forward
male yes I don't know if I would've wore
that that's that and he'd look at the
confidence in that man's face
Manson everybody magic shining on him
mansion MVP is a nationally exactly he
can have very common comment I dare
someone say something about that robber
to him he's 65 to 60 no it's eally Cam
Newton what the we're easy and that's
and that's what he looks that way it was
like I will wear whatever the heck I
want to wear now Russell Westbrook I
believe won best fashion at this year's
NBA act first annual NBA award another
stylist may way that he walks into games
were showing there any one of his many
outfits right now doesn't give a you
know way I would love to be able to just
have that confident in that swag god is
that sadly for a dick seriously not even
for a day like five minutes five minutes
you pull that out I guess it's only a
mindset though Nick right yeah there it
is I get you some glitter shoes get you
a romper how many pairs of Jordans do
you home Oh Jordan man I asked her
collector yeah I stopped counting about
maybe 15 years ago
geez yeah Wow yeah we're in the hundreds
we're weird because obviously I have
younger brothers and stuff so I start to
but the ones that really
you matter to me I hold on to them for
quite some time so I have a whole closet
dedicated to my Jordans age well you
have other clauses within the Jordan
closet you walk in and it's from the
first Jordan all the way to the current
day so what is Jordan I know you and
Jordan have had a relationship unless
you front you designed the was that like
I got an opportunity to do my own wall
and out Jordan they haven't even been
released yet okay we're waiting for
season 10 but it's I have the prototypes
and it's I mean it's been it's a dream
come true I mean like that's that's like
a Oscar Grammy for me is like being able
to you know design one of the shoes I
couldn't even afford when I was a kid
but now it's like to be able to be a
part of that culture it's real for me if
you don't mind me suggesting that
everything's working for you yeah
alright I don't know but I'm gonna
suggest I need I need suggesting some
time here we go
because I think this would go viral as
the kids say oh when that shoe comes out
uh-huh and everybody's going to want a
piece get of that hopefully they're
lining around the block you go back to
where you grew up
yes put on that karate outfit and walk
in with the shoes wait and see who's
beaten who exactly fit then see if they
wanted me maybe Cam Newton can come join
me dressed like that like that you bring
and if you can bring Jordan to write I
can just say how do you like me now how
do you like me now take it all the way
back to the kool Moe Dee day right yeah
absolutely dude I love it well I don't
know we'll go that will go viral
don't you think here's me here's me in
my old karate outfit in my new Jordan in
your new Jordan this that you have
designed where while about yes for
season 10 of any anything is a success
let alone obviously that show absolutely
how have you enjoyed doing that man I've
loved it he started off with you know
the silly improv show that I came up
with you know backstage at a comedy club
with me and my friends that no one had
ever heard of by the name of Kevin Hart
and Katt Williams and all your guys you
know years ago and now you know their
household Superstars and for this show
to kind of be one of the shows that
people were introduced to their comedy
as well as many others for it to still
be going strong and be you know one of
number one shows you know in cable right
now is outstanding yeah and then it's
again on MTV Thursdays at 11:00 Eastern
Time and by the way just one talk about
throwback I heard Total Request Live is
being read RL is coming back by MTV yeah
TRL but Carson's not going to do that
right no long in the tooth to be
requesting long in the tooth yeah you
can't you can go from Total Request Live
to the Today Show yeah not you can't go
back can't go I'm sorry he'll like he'll
come you know shake the new hose hand do
that whole thing pass the baton it was
the last time MTV even played a music
video that's a good question you know
what I think there's at certain times I
think late at night at 3:00 in the
morning really I'm a student of Viacom
so I kind of got a PhD in vibe reality
killed the videos a minute video now the
radios normal it would be because you
know music consumption is bigger than
ever so however they figure our story we
will see well hopefully music comes back
to MTV in a big way there you go
and then as for this film king of the
dance hall which premieres on YouTube
read this Wednesday you wrote you
directed it what is the genesis behind
this story for you is this a personal
story in any way it is in many ways I
mean I took a trip to Kingston Jamaica
promoting some music and artists I was
signing my label and I had never been
before when I got there I was engulfed
in this rich culture and and was blown
away by the passion is like why as a
mainstream media ever experienced what's
here because we see you know Beyonce and
Rihanna and they all borrow from this
culture the you know Drake and Justin
Bieber and Ed share and have hit
dancehall records but no one knows the
story of dancehall so to be able to
share that story in this culture with
the rest of the world is with what I set
out to do so hopefully we'll be able to
do it Dennis the cast I mean good can
Whoopi Goldberg yeah I want to be known
her I've known her for years and to get
the opportunity for her to be my mother
on screen was always a dream so she she
came in and did me the favor is
outstanding well and one Oscar wasn't
enough for you yeah Lou Gossett jr. yes
is in this as well
oh absolutely he's a big clipper guy by
the way I think I mean he's an athlete
ooh easy he's about Cam Newton sighs is
he really a big gu would he would he
wear a romper I don't say Lou Gossett
jr. would be in a romper but like Tim
you can't tell him not to do that okay
absolutely same of the cam has an MVP
he's got an Oscar we were talking about
that the other day Louis Gossett jr.
because it was the 35th anniversary of
officer and a gentleman
Wow last week that and that's one of my
favorite films I mean like him and
Richard Gere together though that was
yeah silver screen magic ring and now
he's a he's in a movie of yours king of
the dance I got a chance to direct new
gossip dunya how was that did you have
to I mean I did I was so focused dirt
mister gossipy of course mr. Gossett
100% but I mean people like that you
give them the character and you just let
them do it and you just make sure the
cameras are turned in their direction
and magic UV a bit okay
well congrats on that and everything
else Nick I'm appreciated it was having
me man is great hanging with you in
South Florida
yeah a lot to say from from
beach-volleyball out of here today look
at us look at us look at us and and
again we have established that Shaq is a
bona fide rapper good rapper good put
the word good in front about what about
an upgrade we won't be seeing him in the
Defiant ones part two is what you're
saying
ha ha ha hey you never know like I said
except my big brother I'm a rock wood
that's another person you're not going
to tell him who I know we he comes on
the show he calls in all the time and I
love him I love him but evil did the
diesel sure Nick Cannon at Nick Cannon
on Twitter and again check out king of
the dancehall on YouTube read this
Wednesday and then season 9 of wild and
out on MTV Thursdays at 11:00 Eastern
I'm the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches